I go to work with my mindset that I'm
not getting any altercations with
anybody
I'm just going to drive if they don't
pay they don't pay
I'm not dealing with that my life is
worth more than two dollars
a two dollar bus ride that cost at least
one passenger his life
from a murder to a supervisor's stab bus
drivers say they've just had enough our
eight news now investigators are
uncovering more explosive incidents
affecting not only passengers but all of
us on the road eight news now
investigator David charns with
wouldn't even take a ride themselves
well Brian Denise we've shown you
drivers pleading for a Transit Police
Department and talking to them I
realized each has a specific reason why
something they've experienced all while
commanding a multi-ton vehicle with
either you on board or you sharing the
road with them
we're in war and we're drivers and we
shouldn't be if driving a bus in Las
Vegas is war these coach operators are
on the front line we literally moved
this city
we like what we do but we shouldn't be
assaulted every day to do it Sandra
Adams Stephanie Davis and Tamisha Davis
four and a half seven twelve more than
two decades among them each with stories
covering all those miles I get cursed at
I get called all kind of names all those
rides what are some of the things you
see on your buses we have people who can
try to harm other people
from arguments
to stabbings
a passenger stealing a bus a man holding
another hostage a supervisor stabbed a
passenger killed these women say they're
fighting a battle they didn't sign up
for coming to work and I'm praying Lord
please protect me
while I'm out here and hope that I make
it home back safely police responded to
more than 2 000 incidents on RTC buses
last year that's a lot
two thousand we got 12 months one every
four hours in an emergency drivers can
push a panic button and alert an
operations center there's a button there
but a lot of them don't work so really
it's
useless there are more than 200 security
guards on buses too RTC says they can
detain passengers if they witness a
crime I've then seen a passenger tell
the security guard you can't do anything
to me get Metro last year security
officers removed more than 118
000 passengers from buses or bus stops
RTC says those actions deterred
potential crimes on board they respond
to a lot of incidents and they prevent a
lot a lot of incidents so obviously we
never talk about the the incidents are
prevented but they that's that's why we
have their primary goal is to prevent
incidents from happening in the first
place Francis Julian is rtc's Deputy CEO
are these buses safe we provided 41
million rides last year so when you look
at the number of incidents versus the
ride on the bus is quite safe in
addition to car it's making it on board
some buses RTC touts a group of roving
security officers able to respond to the
nearest incident they said their
response time is 11 minutes
that's cute
RTC says it's adding more monitors to
respond faster but those drivers say it
is simply not enough to prevent violence
they've experienced themselves